and now if the gentlemen of the
orchestra will turn to their arrangement
we want to play on the undisputed king
and queen of Hollywood musicals Ginger
Rogers and Fred Astaire
play around with that a lot
should we friends no I'll let him live a
little
you're right we're here to present the
awards to the screenwriters for the best
screenplay excuse me Fred oh my baby for
the best screenplay based on material
from another medium the nominees are
bill Naughton four Alfie Robert bolt a
man for all seasons Richard Brook the
professionals William Rose the Russians
are coming the Russians are coming
Ernest Neiman Who's Afraid of Virginia
Woolf ginger would you do the honors
thank you the winner is Robert Boles
you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
you really are incredibly generous to
aliens you've been so generous to me
that I think the time has come for me to
reveal the secret to my success in this
field and my advice to any aspiring
young writer for the film medium is very
simple just make sure that you write for
either David Inge of a dissonant I also
got a couple of metaphorical Oscars of
my own which I want to bestow want to
Bill Graf our executive producer who
brought Freddy and myself together and
suggested that we have a go at it and
the other one - Johnny box who on a
pretty small budget created mock-ups of
various palaces and castles inside and
out which was so good that I I think can
come with a lot of other people when I
first saw them on the rushes thought
they were the real thing
thank you very much I'm very proud to
have this
well the best story and screenplay
written directly for the screen the
nominations are blow up story by Neil
Angelo antonioni screenplay by Nikhil
Angelo antonioni Tonino Guerra and
Edward bond the fortune cookie story and
screenplay by Billy Wilder and I al
diamond carb - story and screenplay by
Robert our drain a man and the woman
story by Claude Lelouch screenplay by
Pierre d800 vane and Claude Lelouch the
naked prey story and screenplay by Clint
Johnston and Don Peters the winner
please up Fred you take it this time you
always have a winner
the winners are Claude the noose and
here
thank you very much
she would ray of Robin conceived for
moccasin alleys the purity of event he
married Cleo Thomas as well Nancy
you'll be decorated by the Gaul